um I just did a lot of damage
but I got a school bag okay
all the things that I got from the Marc Jacobs sample sale
um this is what I'm most excited about
it's this huge huge bag
and like that the handle stays up
even my computer so I'm like
this is a perfect like
winter school bag which I'm excited about
and then I have a bunch of jewelry
I've been wanting stuff from her for so long
I only got a little small thing
red petal like wristlet
so cute but not the exact shade close enough
um but I'm really excited for it
it comes with a little sandy liang uh
duster and there's like
a little pocket for like
little miscellaneous things
I'm really excited about this
okay and then I got jewelry as well
oh I got a top
I got a top
I got a top this is an extra large
and it fit me I put it on my body it made the chi chis look good
and this is the shirt I think it's really cute
and she's very stretchy so it works
then I got these nails $5 press ons
fun exciting
um then I got these earrings
razor blades I feel like that would go to my second hoop
I got this hair clip oh
handcuff this is heaven
or Jacobs very cool
I got these handcuff earrings
they come as one but I just
I bought a pair um
I got this ear cuff which is gonna go like this
it is like a spine
and I think it's all just like
my vibe and then I got some like
razor wire like
earring stuff so it's like
this ear cuff this like
big one um
and there's like
a smaller one for right there
and then there's this one that goes in piercing
and I got all of that for less than the original price of the bag
so I'm like worth it